oh my god yes I'm famous look at this
look at my room look at my room
yes someone found out I write a dress
and they thought they were gonna send us
some stuff hey Felix and Marzia I know
you miss your pugs hope this helps it's
really hard to do with one hand there
you go alright you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
good money today I'm going to a shoot to
promote my book yes so I can since this
is actually my book and it's made to
promote it I can show it bring your
birds along how do I look
yes very fancy it's not every day you
wear a turtleneck alright this is the
same very nice great are they supposed
to be like we don't have the actual
quotes or are they okay yeah yeah they
open yes nice
I'll turn around yeah okay so my place
we'll just do a rehearsal here for
lighting okay ready and action Emerson
inspir ology this first piece entitled
granny gun post Oh demonstrate foodie
pipes exquisite use of Photoshop and
choppy very good this is a great piece
of art a classic I have these cards so I
will remember the lines but I still turn
it reflects but I think it'll be pretty
funny
I can't wait for you breads to see it oh
my god yes I'm famous look at this look
at my room look at my room
yes Doritos or carrots
I just got back it's 5 p.m.
I think there's took a lot more time
than I thought I thought it would be a
quick thing but I haven't vlogged
anything
ok Myanmar's I gotta get groceries I
think and then just a regular good ol
Monday so exciting right yes this is my
favorite going so far I want it so many
beers I've never seen before
what should I get
if I can get it out yes
[Music]
finding yourself
all right
what do you keep doing that so weird
damn that sky is so pretty I got so much
food so exciting yes remember how when I
went swimming a few days ago I think I
got an ear infection so I have to go to
get some medical supplies for my ear
this vlog is my favorite vlog so far I
really enjoy I haven't been in ear pain
huh I thought I went to the beach and
then it's just my right hair yeah yeah
there is something called sweet ear
yeah I heard about that yeah just put a
couple I'm in three four drops is
against this window okay in the middle
of a shelf all right thank you
there's so much medicine yes I'm so
tired
we're just gonna chill tonight oh yes
come with me
I feel so American now we need to treat
my ear yeah do it
uh-huh uh-huh oh that feels weird Oh am
I supposed to stay like this I hope it
works cuz it hurts a lot that's your
chance to be like oh thank you no that's
my only man I'm about to blow your mind
with food part two
done
there's like a 5 out of 10 hey I'm not a
good shot this guy follows me in Twitter
are you jealous are you are you worried
we have a bunch of stuff in front of us
what are they yeah the game when we went
to Little Tokyo we found a bunch of
weird Asian beauty and wellness so we
decided to buy them and we're gonna try
them yes pleasure okay these is supposed
to be for the next put them like that
around your neck like a what I don't
know I don't move
it's possible to massage it by the sense
of they Shack sites ooh so you do it
yourself
Wow you sweet how is that good for you
why are you here I'm a train if you
suffer while I suffer don't do anything
I can are you it's for beyond for the
arms and these are to get slimmer arms
it leads to a beautiful silhouette I'm
jerking off your arm yeah all right I
can dig this this feels okay so there's
the thing you can do with this one you
can adjust this oh I broke it it's
broken now these it's to get a slimmer
that's all there no yeah
I'm gonna picture how this huge you have
to look awkward like well anyway well
but these are too wide though not for me
if you don't do what that's funny that's
funny okay I have a wide nose yeah I
like this one
I don't want your rousing compact this
one second line that's a bit I'm very
excited about that one this is where
your chance to get that that contour
like every day this is me every day
right I doubt it
any painter that one is a three out of
five for me this one is still the
champion this is the big one they had
refresher are you ready
[Music]
can't tell if I like it or not alright
this is not my face while I'm using this
alright
what are you hurts right yeah ah [ __ ]
[Music]
yes the ultimate pleasure is here it
feels so nice I've got to look so good
no don't stop I thought you spend all
that money on this [ __ ] alright we're
done for today I hope you enjoyed
another vlog this has been a great day a
little slow but that's the thing with
daily vlogs you're not always gonna get
ultimate quality but what are we gonna
do now Mart's yes alright brother
I'll see you tomorrow as always stay
awesome
you like my hair which one is real
Murcia many why are you the real one
which is the real
are you the real yes